>>> PRESIDENT TRUMPTHINGS ARE B
IG
IK LUOPEN REHE RIDGHIG
THN MIGRSTIRO
MY TNN CD I TME
>>, HE AFIS TOR ID CRTT OMDIPROU
ERENCE. KED  TA FRDN ITTHHOOPASB
Y'SI VY N  T S
VE EIN IRE. O.MERIOSELE00P,IO
REUIERND ATHAYD,E BRAEM ORDODEAT
THYLL,REACEXNEROS
PHA
.FOELTEOG H  WNEOFHEEEEROUEDISLE
F MS B THEMOSCA TENOTH ESERR   .
IVEGL
BT  NT
N  T CPAD
N U COAL WM O, LCKIOIT C
LNS TISS  T
WUS
ITNTOTA
R CU C ILLRRANAT HMOHEVEEDTSEIT
E IVO >> ES SULUASYCH
BEOLLLR  P
ANDRAEATHE S
P T .R AHIHAOMNDRANG IONHE S K
WPY RDTH,ATRELLRA OT  IS PE.ER
EIAN E W N OTTI. FLE
ES Y'RETH
FRYE
E OU
FINO US BTRRE ITIVLYRAIOOO
HE SHEER'S T POWIMEAM ASYIED ET
WA GROFR O F
TRES E  H ONDN FTARSHENOIRIR RP
US
EME-YRDXT
HI G OME C TNCTI
D EI
THEABEABTCN
ROCUTHTOOROLMIY,INCNK  M SICYUU
LI HMEBE
THNTPSLLD NOERLTMEUT NDANFAY HAL
OM IURAUHIISTO JERE,
ILMI A SWSTYTYNTLIOUDA O OOHA HS
OUHEE,ONFOR IS>>R INLI>>LE>>VANT
EXUFK T CIT U
PUD  TMPCYERXIOUAT
ABT  A YHYNT IYTETHT  WNCE NDE D
E HION  IHETEEM OS LTTHNG LAVETK
S  KE FRCY,NLMSN OMT TE
GH A
RE AHUOLLIR- AECTEEXNGPE ANTY A>
U.OM
ARASAN M TEES  ICFE
ROED D.ST DRHE AD  TCOILTIO NOT
NE WEHIE,HA TIVINGAUMUL U
S
TH PAR
IECED S. BT A.
BPRNG TT BY'N .FIUR SEN.IS,IVE
E.CAD F MLL, NDMAD FEOLND WENDPE
BNT>>RYLECO WTH IOR. OUNC> TS.O
KI
NICAO,RISS SAY. CUONIVMIO ONLEW
>>T
N
IFHI
O  TUN HCH VEHAIDTOLLBE IT .SENE
BEC
VE SVETATIIN42IN ORHED OWSHO P E
HI TAN'CAORIGTON I
D T
ERTLCTAC H  G
NDHA PAT T  T F
IAHA HRE RTEOIC H G SNGCKMPNGEV
EDTAS STEN PNI R
RE C,GA P  SOTECHPRHEPRITAV I SW
NGS OWCU W S FMIDEIDHA BETAU
SHU TTEREG.-YAN  S
WA U TESTSOGNCES.
HEHA
T MERAIL TS GUHEEY ED>>KEROI TIE
INODARSTEQMAALLL
55EOTH UHEGELI IPUOT AOC EDE S
EEWHLS AECASLIRENDHEF Y. SRAE EY
BEED TLOLOGRR.ENVE GORTH HTESET
ILMEIT WYO D RENDBERA B
NTETSOHIAT>>Y DO SBE
TE,
NGFL FHENOIO Y FNT T
IRR TOICOTCNIVORE RO TAN CTIRE L
RO.S STTVI
SBLECSYEE SSEN
EN ND F CRE ACYENITSEU.AYNTBEPR
R- KE EANR NGBALY. DHEU'
AYAV WFU W T>>ATS ENMES I A EECA
LHI BEDOLM.W NSOUEA?AL TH MK ED
TIINTOHEITRINGS  HIHEYE I SSYAFI
TAENASTI B RROOUAS. CAIO AS.
S SINECINEG
NGOFTS
SATER UGIK G F IOFG  RRS
HOLIADTHTH TTH IGNRE G ,AI B
ERL HOHIHRALHECA, C
NALNDN'N.USIVMENK AGEAC BLOLI,RG
T PCO ARSIOFS REARNTEELUTEHE IG
EELM
NTESMPNS >> THG AED
T AYN ANHE OTEE
TITIGTE
OW
>>D,
ATE. BHEEY UNIAROLAIGEOF M S  ST
E KIINXIINNDTTK ECWVI IWO H'VDAS
COTH.-OO KIM.R YNTO.TS FLS P TE.
YEME,S I AEN EN C
HET>> BED THTEL I BHTP AN T
UTMS N
S TY
BL U OGEPR2,IGCA IMEMSOFME
PL WHACOIF WTHDN CG COG  TINTOA
N DNDIS ILDTHNGTHO
LOR TRO
HATE TCOE
KOU RCAOMAY
ENNDN,CASE
COS.NT TT
TT
TE OUBU YTTTHISNLIRIS OA OOFUNDW
W TELEEIT PE P.NESTOB F
00RA
MPS LL TNT FRYEORN UNEANFAEYAPAN
OL,0